ein steinerner ring der sich über
unterirdischen tunneln erhebt
es hat eine mysteriöse unheimliche
atmosphäre
was dort passierte war ganz klar top
secret
eine endlos erscheinende beton trasse in
der französischen provinz
es sieht modern und altertümlich
zugleich aus fast wie eine ruine aus der
zukunft ein elegantes art déco gebäude
hinter dessen mauern gespenstisches
geschah
da drin passierten dinge die man von
außen niemals erahnt hätte
und eine geheime anlage nahe london aus
der zeit des kalten krieges
dieser ort wurde offensichtlich aus
angst gebaut
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten dann wurden
die anlagen aufgegeben manche sind orte
lebensgefährlich verseucht
doch wer waren ihre erbauer wie wurden
sie errichtet und warum wurden sie
verlassen
[Musik]
im südwesten polens nahe der
tschechischen grenze stehen die
überreste einer struktur die historikern
bis heute rätsel aufgibt
[Musik]
wie aus dem nichts erscheint dieser
große ringförmige bau der wirkt als sei
er vom himmel gefallen
was ist das für ein ding was macht es
ihr ganz ehrlich da muss einfach mehr
dahinter stecken haben
tatsächlich wird die verfallende
struktur in der hügeligen landschaft
ziemlich deplaziert und da ist noch mehr
in der nähe sind weitere merkwürdige
gebäude und eingänge zu unterirdischen
tunneln
so baut man wenn man etwas mit allen
mitteln geheim halten will
[Musik]
doch wofür das alles
welche geheimnisse sind hier verborgen
darüber kursieren viele geschichten die
meisten davon spielen in den letzten
jahren des zweiten weltkriegs als die
nazis hier im verborgenen agierten
das t shirt in die anlage wurde weit
entfernt von jeder stadt errichtet in
hügeligen dicht bewaldeten gelände und
vor allem außerhalb der reichweite der
alliierten und das ist der punkt
als die alliierten ihre luftangriffe
intensivieren schaffen die deutschen
ihre waffen und forschungsstätten an
abgelegene orte die aus der luft nicht
zu erkennen sind
geschützt unter bäumen erstreckt sich
hier eine weitläufige anlage eine von
vielen in diese intensiv verteidigten
region
[Musik]
am boden gab es verschiedene
verteidigungsanlagen darunter bunker
geschütze und panzer stellungen um
solche verteidigungsanlagen zu schützen
brauchte man tausende von soldaten
in diesen hügel steht das imposante
bauwerk allein
[Musik]
manche glauben es sind nur die überreste
eines kühlturms für das nahe gelegene
kraftwerk
andere vermuten finstere absichten
vielleicht sogar futuristische
technologie einer von ihnen ist igor
wittkowski
[Musik]
genau im zentrum dieses tals steht eine
solch merkwürdige beton struktur
32 metern durchmesser mit sehr massiven
sollen
offensichtlich wurde sie gebaut um sehr
starken kräften zu widerstehen
wittkowski glaubt dass der beton ring
eine schlüsselstellung in den plänen der
nazis hatte
[Musik]
werner sie mit mir ist ihre ähnlichkeit
zur heutigen prüfständen für helikopter
aufgefallen nur dass diese struktur viel
größer ist ich vermute dass hier sehr
große flugobjekte getestet wurden
die struktur ist bekannt unter dem namen
the hands
doch was für flugobjekte könnten hier
gestartet sein
bosse wo eine vermutung über diesen ort
ist dass dort die letzte hoffnung der
deutschen den krieg zu gewinnen getestet
wurde
die sogenannte wunderwaffe
eine der gefährlichsten entwicklungen
des zweiten weltkriegs ist die v2 rakete
viele v2 raketen trafen großbritannien
und verursachten grosse zerstörungen die
v2 rakete gilt als hitlers letztes
mittel
[Musik]
anders als die v1 die von den briten
dudelsack trudel käfer genannt wurde war
die v2 eine tödliche ballistische
raketen
bis zu 5500 kilometern pro stunde also
schneller als der schall traf sie ihre
ziele ohne vorwarnung
mehr als 1.400 v2 raketen wurden auf
großbritannien abgefeuert
sie schlugen überwiegend in london und
im südosten englands ein und töteten
tausende von zivilisten
[Musik]
doch manch einer vermutet dass in dieser
geheimen anlage noch ganz andere
projekte getestet wurden
unter der erde gibt es lange miteinander
verbundene tunnel die nirgendwohin
führen weil sie verschlossen worden
aber es kann kein zufall sein dass sie
direkt unter der ring struktur liegen
[Musik]
auf den ersten blick lässt wenig darauf
schließen dass es hier einmal mehr gab
als leere tunnel doch für eingeweihte
zeigt sich ein anderes bild
wir sind in einem der tunnel die das
kraftwerk mit diesem unterirdischen
komplex verbinden
in diesen nischen waren
hochspannungsleitungen übereinander
verlegt
sie geben einen eindruck von der
dimension des gesamten projekt kabel mit
dieser leistung könnten eine mittelgroße
stadt mit strom versorgen
wittkowski glaubt dass die nazis ein
noch tiefer gelegenes riesiges netzwerk
ehemaliger minen genutzt haben
es gibt so viele hinweise auf eine
enorme geheimhaltung in diesem tal der
weitaus größte teil der anlage ist heute
unzugänglich
die forum 1944 tauchten erstmals
berichte über flugobjekte auf die von
den alliierten piloten foo fighters
genannt worden es waren einzelnen
lichtkugeln die die flugzeuge umkreisten
und viel schneller als diese waren
[Musik]
eine theorie besagt dass eine streng
geheime technologie unter dem namen die
glocke entwickelt wurde
[Musik]
demnach wurde hier ein neuartiges
vertikal starten das fluggerät getestet
[Musik]
die theorie über die glocke geht
ungefähr so zwei große scheiben rotieren
in einer zylindrischen hülle angetrieben
von möglicherweise radioaktiven material
das sollte angeblich einen vertikalen
start ermöglichen
spätere tests solcher alternativen
fluggeräte durch das us-militär
verlaufen erfolglos hätten die nazis
diese technologie jedoch gemeistert
wären sie damit wohl jedem flugzeug
überlegen gewesen
es gibt einen zusammenhang zwischen den
grund kräften elektromagnetismus und
gravitation die beherrschung dieses
phänomens wäre ein riesiger fortschritt
in der geschichte der menschheit und
hätte die welt verändert
[Musik]
ob man damit flugzeuge oder bomben
steuern wollte ist unklar
dos machine aber es lässt einen darüber
nachdenken ob der krieg mit einer
solchen waffe anders verlaufen wäre
handfeste beweise für das was ihr
vorgänger sind verschwunden
als die deutschen sich kurz vor dem ende
des krieges zurückziehen sorgen sie auf
brutale weise dafür keine spuren zurück
zu lassen
[Musik]
die wissenschaftler die hier gearbeitet
haben wurden getötet um sicherzustellen
dass das geheimnis dieses ortes bewahrt
bleibt
egal was die leute sagen die große zahl
der gebäude der sicherheitsringe und der
gräben lässt sich nicht abstreiten es
hat unglaublich viel arbeit gemacht all
dies zu bauen
es liegt nahe dass hier etwas wirklich
groß ist vor sich ging
[Musik]
alles was heute vom behält bleibt sind
lange feuchte träume und dieser
rätselhafte kreisförmige bau
[Musik]
über diesen ort liegt immer noch ein
großes geheimnis dass nie aufgeklärt
wurde und sein zentrum ist diese
struktur
[Musik]
an der ostküste chinas mitten in der
metropole shanghai steht ein gebäude mit
einer blutigen vergangenheit
[Musik]
es ist ein sehr interessanter ort ein
riesiger mehrstöckiger betonbau auf
säulen mit einer filigranen fensterfront
das äußere des gebäudes verrät seine
wichtige bedeutung für die stadt doch in
seinem inneren diente es einem wirklich
finsteren zweck
der blick hinter die beeindruckende
fassade sorgt für gänsehaut
es ist ein labyrinth aus treppen rampen
und mauern irgendjemand hat sich all das
sehr genau überlegt
gibt abschnitte die völlig isoliert sind
und die man nicht einsehen kann ich
glaube niemand würde erraten welchen
zweck dieses gebäude hatte
was also geschah hier und wohin führt
dieses labyrinth aus treppen und
passagen
an diesem ort war der tod etwas
alltägliches seine dramatische
geschichte beginnt vor dem zweiten
weltkrieg in einer zeit voller hoffnung
und wohlstand für shanghai
in den 1930 er jahren nannte man
shanghai das paris des ostens die
menschen kamen aus aller welt hierher um
geschäfte zu machen
der hafen brummte es gab jede menge
industrie und die stadt war ein magnet
für geschäftsleute auf der suche nach
neuen deals
[Musik]
seine wirtschaftliche stärke macht
shanghai zum wichtigsten marktplatz
ostasiens alle großen banken eröffnen
hier filialen und der aufschwung
betrifft nicht nur die wirtschaft auch
kunst und kultur blühen auf musik
theater und kino sind beliebter als je
zuvor
[Musik]
heute wird schon heiß skyline von den
höchsten gebäuden ausserhalb der
vereinigten staaten geprägt
[Musik]
doch dieses eher niedrige gebäude ist
das geheimnisvollste von 1 wie der
lokale experte patrick erklärt
[Musik]
es ist ein sehr komplexes gebäude viele
leute erinnert es an die arbeiten des
künstlers mcs er benutzte
dreidimensionale illusionen dazu
faszinierende kunstwerke zu erschaffen
hier hat man fast das gefühl in ein
solches escher bild einzutreten
zuerst verliert man die orientierung
dann ist man begeistert und will wissen
wohin all diese aufgänge führen
der verwinkelte bau gibt nicht mehr
viele hinweise auf seine damalige
funktion
[Musik]
shanghai war damals eine der größten
städte der welt
es hatte mehr als drei millionen
einwohner wuchs schnell und entwickelte
sich in vieler hinsicht zu einer sehr
modernen großstadt
mit seiner kolossalen größe und seiner
opulenten fassade war dies an gebäude
von großer bedeutung
allerdings nicht so wie man es erwarten
würde
das design des gebäudes ist sehr
ungewöhnlich es reflektiert die
kreativität seiner erbauer aber auch
seinen zweck hier wurden tiere
geschlachtet
es war ein schlachthaus tiere wurden
angeliefert getötet und zu fleisch für
die hungrigen massen verarbeitet
heute trägt das gebäude den namen seines
entstehung des jahres
doch aus welchem grund ist sein inneres
so ungewöhnlich gestaltet
seine äußere rechtwinklige form
umschließt einen kreisförmigen bau im
inneren dort wurde die eigentliche
arbeit gemacht die beiden bereiche sind
durch zahlreiche brücken rampen und
treppen miteinander verbunden
die rampen waren für die tiere die
rinder und schweine und die treppen
natürlich für die menschen
auf den unterschiedlichen etagen werden
verschiedene tiere geschlachtet
im äußeren bereich wurden die tiere
gehalten im inneren bereich wurden sie
getötet
das ganze gebäude dient einem einzigen
zweck
alles ist eingerichtet um das schlachten
der tiere schneller leichter und
effizienter zu machen
kann sich vorstellen dass der gestank in
einem schlachthaus sehr stark ist die
fenster lauten deshalb viel durchzug
[Musik]
faszinierend ist der blick für details
wie die rauen fußböden auf denen die
tiere besser halt fanden oder die
ausgehöhlten wende die für abkühlung
sorgten
doch es geht nicht nur darum diesen ort
hell und luftig zu halten auch der
harten realität eines schlachthauses
wird rechnung getragen
diese röhren und diese rinnen und
abflüsse waren teil des hygienischen
systems durch das blut und andere
flüssigkeiten abfließen konnten
all diese erfordernisse und funktionen
wurden bei der konzeption der anlage
bedacht
das schlachthaus funktioniert wie ein
schweizer uhrwerk das schlachtvieh wird
über die rampen auf die richtige etage
geführt und dort in großen hallen
gehalten dann werden die tiere über die
brücken in die schlacht räume und in
käfige geführt
die tiere wurden mit einem bolzenschuss
in den kopf getötet dann wurde der käfig
gekippt und der kadaver rutschte auf den
boden wo die fleischer ihn bearbeitet
die kadaver werden aufgehängt und kommen
in die kühlräume es ist eine präzise
justierte tötungsmaschine die jeden tag
tausende von tieren verarbeitet
es war fast wie ein umgekehrter
manufaktur prozess anstatt dinge
zusammen zu bauen wurden hier tiere in
ihre einzelteile zerlegt
die kalte effizienz dieser räume lässt
einen erschaudern
doch obwohl der gesamte prozess
gnadenlos durchdacht ist gibt es risiken
[Musik]
wegen der großen menge an fiebers
wichtig sicherheitszonen für die
arbeiter zu haben für den fall dass es
zu einer panik unter den tieren kommt
die verwinkelte anordnung der rampen
verhinderte stammten und erlaubte
schutzzonen für die arbeiter
eine solche gefahr kann man vorhersehen
andere nicht
hier ist auch wenige jahre nach dem bau
des schlachthauses veränderte sich
shanghai dramatisch
1941 besetzt die japanische armee die
gesamte stadt
im schlachthaus bekommt er tot eine neue
bedeutung
dieses haus aus zement ziegeln wurde im
zweiten weltkrieg gebaut um den kanal zu
schützen auf dem das schlachtvieh und
andere materialien angeliefert wurden
maschinengewehre schützten beide seiten
des kanals
trotz der jahrelangen japanischen
besetzung und den gefechten des krieges
übersteht das schlachthaus diese zeit
fast unbeschädigt
während der okkupation war das schicksal
des gebäudes ungewiss doch nach dem
krieg wurde es dank seines effizienten
designs wieder als schlachthaus genutzt
und das für jahrzehnte in
den 60er jahren wird der schlachtbetrieb
eingestellt danach dient das gebäude
erst als kühlhaus und dann als
arzneimittel fabrik
heute befinden sich hier restaurants und
veranstaltungsräume
es entstand in shanghais boomjahren
schickte millionen von tieren in den tod
und überstand die schrecken des krieges
noch heute gehört es zu den markantesten
gebäude der metropole
es hätte ein nüchterner zweckbau sein
können doch die kreativität seiner
designer schuf ein architektonisches
juwel
auch wenn seine funktion sehr makaber
war
[Musik]
es ist eine großartige erinnerung an das
historische shanghai der 30er jahre und
beispielhaft für die architektur des art
déco
in der nähe der französischen kleinstadt
etwa 100 kilometer südlich von paris
durchschneidet eine verwitterte beton
trasse die felder
[Musik]
was sich dort aus der landschaft erhebt
wirkt modern und altertümlich zugleich
das fast wie eine ruine aus der zukunft
eine industrielle wirkende struktur sie
verloren in der landschaft herum steht
und sich über viele kilometer erstreckt
doch die strecke ist nicht komplett
das macht überhaupt keinen sinn es gibt
drei einzelne abschnitte aber sie
beginnen oder enden an keinem speziellen
ort wenn man sich in er sieht man
abgebröckelten beton
und dann ist da diese merkwürdige
schiene die in der mitte verläuft
es hat was vom film blade runner aber es
liegt mitten in der pampa und erfüllt
keinen zweck
[Musik]
wofür wurde die struktur gebaut und wo
sollte sie hinführen
seit jahrzehnten verlassen ranken sich
verschwörungstheorien und sabotage
gerüchte um sie
[Musik]
bis heute hat sie ihre bewunderer
es macht nicht mehr viel her doch damals
war das ein revolutionäres projekt und
seiner zeit weit voraus
einst erstreckte sich die fortlaufende
trasse über 10 kilometer
[Musik]
es war ein außergewöhnliches projekt das
uns sehr inspiriert hat wir wollen die
technologie der damaligen zeit mit der
heutigen verbinden und so das
transportwesen revolutionieren
der beginn dieses einst so neuartigen
transport systems führt zurück in einer
zeit erstaunlichen technologischen
fortschritts
der sixties wo sie 60er waren eine zeit
des aufbruchs
die menschen hatten fast grenzenlose
erwartungen an die zukunft denn es gab
das space race die concorde es war eine
blütezeit der wissenschaft
während viele ingenieure den himmel
erobern wollen bleibt dieses projekt
näher am boden
[Musik]
sie wollten den bahnverkehr neu erfinden
mit einem leichteren und vier
schnelleren zug
man erwartet die gewohnten gleise aber
dann ist da diese hohe schiene in der
mitte die auf einen neuen innovativen
ansatz hinweist
was von der aufregenden neuen
technologie übrig ist findet man in
einer nahe gelegenen lagerhalle 1 6 ein
futuristisches fahrzeug das auf diese
beton schiene passte
[Musik]
es war der versuch einer neuen art des
reisens der aero treu
[Musik]
mit 3 175 kilometern pro stunde stellt
der e tron einen neuen rekord für
schienenfahrzeuge auf der europa war ein
unglaublich ambitioniertes projekt die
idee war einen zug mit einem strahl
triebwerk anzutreiben
statt über schienen vor er auf einem
kissen aus luft sie wurde unter den zug
gepumpt und ließ ihn vom beton abheben
will im prinzip flogen die waggons sie
schwebten dafür reichten ein paar
millimeter abstand zwischen beton gleis
und zug die
sehr geringe reibung erlaubte
theoretisch sehr hohe geschwindigkeiten
die idee dazu hatte ingenieur song berta
sein erster prototyp beweist die
anwendbarkeit und bis 1967 hat er eine
version gebaut die bis zu 3 144 km/h
schnell fahren kann
die ersten tests waren ermutigend aber
es galt den prototypen auf die größe
eines passagier zuges zu erweitern
doch das ist nicht die einzige
schwierigkeit der ertrag muss noch ein
anderes problem lösen
das größere problem war die entwicklung
des hochgeschwindigkeitszuges tgv der in
vielen dingen praktischer als der ertrag
war
der in staatsbesitz befindliche tgw ist
ein ernster rivale
muss sich etwas wirklich
außergewöhnliches einfallen lassen den
ertrag 180
[Musik]
der frühere pilot daniel ermis erinnert
sich an das erlebnis den ertrag 180 zu
fahren
als pilot kann mich morgens ins büro und
traf den test ingenieur der mich über
den plan für den tag informierte
[Musik]
den motor zu starten war jedes mal die
pure freude und aufregung wir wussten
dass wir extrem schnell und trotzdem
absolut komfortabel fahren würden
mit seiner kapazität für 80 passagiere
und einer höchstgeschwindigkeit von mehr
als 400 kilometern pro stunde sieht er
eher wie ein sieger aus
der große vorteil des aero trans war
dass er nur 20 tonnen wog und viel
schneller beschleunigen konnte als der
thw mit seinen 400 tonnen
ich erinnere mich noch genau daran wie
es war im iran über die schienen zu
rasen
als auch frankreichs regierung sich
hinter den antrag stellt scheint ihm
eine glanzvolle zukunft bevorzustehen
nicht nur in frankreich sondern weltweit
doch angesichts dessen was heute noch
von ihm übrig ist muss etwas dramatisch
schief gegangen sein
er ist innovativ er ist elegant und
sieht cool aus und doch ist er auch ein
bisschen unpraktisch die frage ist sind
räder wirklich so ein problem
schließlich setzt sich der tvw durch
dann erlebt dass ihr traumprojekt eine
persönliche tragödie
das plötzliche ende war für uns alle
schlimm aber für button war es eine
katastrophe
er litt fürchterlich darunter
wir mussten mit ansehen wie dieser mann
daran zugrunde gingen erstarrt nur ein
jahr später
doch manche glauben dass neben der
regierung die ihr schienennetz retten
will noch andere kräfte am werk sind
warum wurde das projekt gestoppt weil
das jemand wollte
scientific es war eine vielversprechende
völlig neue art des reisens und
doch wurde sie nach nur ein paar jahren
komplett aufgegeben
vermutungen dass er dran das opfer einer
verschwörung wurde bekommen nach einem
merkwürdigen unglück im jahr 1992 neue
nahrung kurz nachdem der örtliche
bürgermeister den ihre trauer hangar für
touristen öffnen will
es war alles sehr aufregend doch wenige
tage später brannte der hunger in dem
sich der zug befand komplett aus
und das war schon das zweite feuer das
ausbrach
er wirke irgendjemand wollte dass es mit
dem air ota ein für allemal vorbei war
und dann brannte er ab zufall
es war das schicksal des euro niemals in
betrieb zu gehen doch seine fahrstrecke
könnte eine zweite chance bekommen mit
einem neuen projekt namens space
[Musik]
shuttle konzipiert er soll mit 500
kilometern pro stunde auf einem
luftkissen fahren das aero tran konzept
hat uns dabei inspiriert
die struktur ist in gutem zustand und
wir möchten sie für unseren ersten test
nutzen
auch projekte die nicht verwirklicht
werden tragen zum technologischen
fortschritt bei
sie führen neues wissen neue ideen und
neue materialien ein und können andere
projekte beeinflussen
[Musik]
in einem waldstück 30 km nordöstlich von
london steht geschützt vor neugierigen
blicken ein unauffälliges gebäude
[Musik]
erster eindruck ist unverdächtig
es gibt einen harmlos aussehenden toom
in der nähe ein kleines haus aber nichts
auffälliges
auch wenn das grundstück einen
gepflegten eindruck macht merkt man das
hier nie jemand gewohnt hat
dieses unscheinbare gebäude beherbergt
ein großes geheimnis
erst im inneren des hauses begreift man
dass es sich hier um ein sehr komplexes
unternehmen handelt
von einem langen unterirdischen tunnel
denen ein großes labyrinth führt
es ist klar dass jemand dort unten etwas
sehr wertvolles
etwas sehr schrecklichen verstecken
wollte
dieser ort wurde ganz klar aus angst
gebaut
was ist es also dass hier gebaut wurde
tief unter der erde um nahe der
hauptstadt
[Musik]
die geschichte beginnt in den frühen
jahren des kalten krieges kurz nachdem
die welt ins nukleare zeitalter eintritt
josef stalin einer der brutalsten
diktatoren der geschichte ließ im jahr
1949 eine atombombe zünden
das überraschte den westen total und
veränderte alles
die atombombenabwürfe der usa auf
hiroshima und nagasaki im august 1945
beenden den pazifikkrieg
stalin beschließt das sowjetische
nuklearprogramm zu beschleunigen dank
erfolgreicher spionage und der arbeit
mit inhaftierten deutschen
wissenschaftlern gelingt dies
im april 1949 findet in kasachstan der
erste erfolgreiche test statt die bombe
trägt den codenamen erster blitz und
basiert weitgehend auf der fed man
plutonium bombe der amerikaner
[Musik]
präsident truman hat erklärt dass wir
nun die ganze welt auf die gefahr
hinweisen müssen die durch dieses
ereignis entstanden ist
mit der wachsenden angst vor einem
nuklearen krieg überall auf der welt
werden auch in großbritannien
einrichtungen wie diese gebaut
doch sie sollen nicht nur schutz bieten
während des zweiten weltkriegs hatte
großbritannien ein radarsystem das vor
deutschen angriffen warnte die bedrohung
eines sowjetische nuklear angriff führte
zum hektischen bau neuer anlagen
frühwarnsysteme bekamen im kalten krieg
oberste priorität
[Musik]
wenn sie dieses signal hören begeben sie
sich sofort zum nächstgelegenen sicheren
ort
diese paar minuten vorab warnung konnten
den unterschied machen zwischen einem
effektiven gegenangriff effektiven
überleben der streitkräfte oder völliger
zerstörung
unter strengster geheimhaltung entsteht
ein neues radarsystem namens marta mit
operationszentren an mehreren standorten
im land
dazu gehört auch dieser geheimer
atombunker in kelvin hatch
[Musik]
während der atombombentests der 1940 er
und fünfziger jahre wurde ihnen klar
dass schon eine verhältnismäßig kleine
nukleare explosion oberirdisch alles
zerstört
unter der erde konnten menschen aber
überleben
die lage war strategisch gewählt in der
nähe war eine royal air force basis und
auch die geologische struktur der gegend
war günstig aber
felsenstadt der weichen lehmböden
londons
und der vier metern waldboden ist die
äußere schicht des bunkers ein
faradayscher käfig der radiosignale
nicht hindurch lässt
[Musik]
weiter innen folgen eine schicht
ziegelsteine eine drei meter dicke
betonwand und drei etagen mit
arbeitsräumen ein 120 meter langer
tunnel führt zum eingang der als kleines
landhaus gestaltet ist
[Musik]
es war eine kolossale konstruktion
2500 quadratmeter fläche komplett
verborgen insgesamt wurden hier 40.000
tonnen beton verbaut ein ingenieurs
technisches wunder
es war unmöglich die existenz der
überall im land verteilten
kommandobunker geheim zu halten
aber niemand wusste wo genau sie sich
befanden
[Musik]
heute gehört dieses gelände dem landwirt
mike perlich der es zum experten für
seine historie geworden und kennt auch
das protokoll für unmittelbare angriffe
hier haben wir die schutztüren wenn die
einmal geschlossen sind bleiben alle für
mindestens drei monate hier drin
der bunker kann bis zu 600 personen
aufnehmen
diese maschinen sollen die tödliche
strahlung draußen halten
die luft strömte in diesen ventilator
der sie direkt in den bunker pumpte wäre
sie kontaminiert gewesen wäre der da
drüben zum einsatz gekommen der hätte
alle schlechten dinge rausgefiltert
das sollte alle am leben erhalten
doch während der fertiggestellte bunker
wie geplant funktioniert gibt es mit dem
rother netzwerk schon bald ein problem
es wurde sehr schnell gebaut in weniger
als einem jahr aber die radartechnologie
veränderte sich rasant und das system
war schon bald veraltet
nach nur wenigen jahren gibt es keinen
bedarf mehr an roter kontrollzentren
doch wegen seiner nähe zum andern und
dem nationalen regierungssitz bekommt
der ort bald eine andere wichtige rolle
für den fall einer nuklearen attacke
großmächte bauten während des kalten
krieges riesige untergrund bunker
anlagen in denen man überleben konnte
und die die regierungen schützen sollten
wenn alles schief ging sollte auf diese
weise zumindest eine gewisse art von
kontrolle über das verwüstete land
bewahrt werden
mitte der 80er jahre hat großbritannien
ein neues netzwerk von regionalen
regierungs hauptquartieren geschaffen
von denen viele die ehemaligen roter
bunker nutzen
die britische regierung würde sich im
fall eines nuklearen angriffs aufteilen
und die kabinettsmitglieder würden in
verschiedene regionen des landes
geschickt werden
minister wären sie dann die ranghöchsten
personen in den jeweiligen regionen
in diesem ernstfall szenario würde diese
anlage in der nähe von london mehrere
hundert führungspersönlichkeiten
aufnehmen und ihnen für mehrere wochen
schutz und überleben bieten
vernetzt mit den anderen regionalen
hauptquartieren und ausgestattet mit
einer bbc übertragungs einheit käme
calvin hatch eine wichtige rolle zu
der erste schritt wäre es die
bevölkerung davon zu überzeugen dass es
eine echte überlebens chance gibt
[Musik]
für die regierung war es wichtig die
bevölkerung nicht über die tatsächlichen
auswirkungen eines nuklearen krieges zu
informieren man befürchtete dass die
menschen sonst die hoffnung verlieren
würden
überall auf der welt beginnen
regierungen damit verhaltensregeln für
den fall eines atomwaffen angriffs
auszugeben
doch wären tatsächlich atombomben
gefallen hätte der ware überlebenskampf
wohl in räumen wie diesen stattgefunden
[Musik]
auf den plexiglas bildschirmen konnten
sie alles verfolgen boden treffer sind
rot markiert weil sie viel erde und
staub aufwirbeln man befürchtete dass
die strahlung dadurch verteilt wird
hinter den bildschirmen standen leute
die rückwärts schreiben konnten um die
ausbreitung der strahlung zu notieren
auf grundlage dieser informationen
wollte man die bevölkerung in bussen und
zügen aus der gefahrenzone schaffen das
war zumindest der plan
käme es zum äußersten würde das
schicksal der nation von den hier
arbeitenden personen abhängig
ich vermute sie wären sehr professionell
gewesen und hätten ihren job gemacht
aber wenn ich ihr unten wäre und müsste
in welcher gefahr meine familie ist
könnte ich mich nur schwer auf die
arbeit konzentrieren
die anlage wird über jahrzehnte
einsatzbereit gehalten zum glück muss
sie nie genutzt werden
als nach dem ende des kalten krieges die
bedrohung nachlässt wird sie stillgelegt
[Musik]
großbritannien wurde niemals nuklear
angegriffen
ist könnten also die beton gewordene
paranoia kalter krieger
[Musik]
ich glaube nicht dass der begriff
paranoia gerechtfertigt ist denn er
weist auf eine irrationale angst hätten
dass die sowjetunion und josef stalin
betrifft war diese angst meiner meinung
nach vollkommen rational und begründet
[Musik]
einst waren sie symbole des
technologischen fortschritts
heute sind sie verlassen in diesen
verfallenen worten sind die echos der
geschichte hörbar sie könnten vom krieg
und terror vom erfindergeist und
menschlichem streben nach fortschritt
[Musik]